hello everyone and welcome to today's
live of poster presentation anti body
purification development of two new
highly efficient purification resins
presented by Aaron McBride a RNG
scientist in protein and cell analysis
at Thermo Fisher Scientific I'm Cindy
Valdez and I will be your moderator for
today's educational webcast presented by
lab roots and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during this presentation just click
on that green Q&A button located at the
lower left of your presentation window
and type your questions into the box
that appears on the screen well answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
poster in a slide window to enlarge that
window just click on the screen icon
located on the lower right if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem without further ado please
join me in welcoming Erin McBride I will
now turn the presentation over to him
welcome Erin thank you Susie
in today's talks I will talk through a
poster titled antibody rafin development
of two highly efficient purification
rhythms and outlining the benefits of
these two new antibody purification
resins purification can vastly different
from antibody to antibody however the
initial capture step can be fairly
similar most antibodies will be captured
by one of four class clamp affinity
ligands protein a protein G protein a/g
or protein L what's the ligand and the
resin combination that truly makes the
resin unique the chromatography spork
and influence final purity similar to
the lion we can also influence
how you run your purification the beige
resin can influence maximum flow rates
illusion volumes and binding capacities
all of which impact the total efficiency
of your purification scheme in this
presentation will describe protein g and
protein a/g
on Thermo Fisher Scientific porous for
fusion chromatography media these resins
offer significant advantages due to the
unique properties of the porous beads
and provides up to four fold higher
binding capacity when compared to a
similar growth based resin well first
let's discuss the different ligands the
classical ligands for antibody
purification are either virgin a or
protein g protein a binds at the ch2 ch3
club but can also bind the bh3 variable
region allow it to bite some fats
protein ATS in the majority of the
antibody purification students better
chemical tolerance and milder Aleutian
conditions the disadvantage of protein a
is that it does not by an IgG 3 and does
not find all facts perching G is similar
to protein a that it binds to the ch2
ch3 cleft but also binds to the CH one
domain allow it to bind all fats in
addition protein G binds igg3 and has
poor binding to other IgG subtypes such
as ITA and IgM the disadvantage to use
in protein G is that it does have lower
chemical tolerance than protein a and a
lower pH is needed for Ellucian while
the majority of purifications are
binding a human or humanized
IgG antibody there is also significant
amount of purifications that deal with
non human antibodies the specificity of
protein a and protein gh and non-human a
device can vary greatly and when
choosing a ligand for a non human
antibody each protein binding
characteristics should be examined in
most cases protein and protein g are
complementary and that defer teen age
does not bind or binds weakly to one
species protein GU will bind strong to
that species now for Liza I are doing
purification on a wide range of
antibodies there is protein a g8 protein
a/g is a chimeric protein that
find the five antibody binding site of
protein a and two antibody binding sites
of protein G for all-in-one resin as
mentioned previously the residents will
talk about have either protein G or
protein a/g mobilized to the poorest
base be this first graph compares
dynamic binding capacity using human IgG
for both Kouros mat capture G select
protein G sepharose for fat loss and
protein g plus argos presence on the y
axis we have DBC and on the x axis we
have multiple flow rates nad capture g
select maintains close to double the
binding capacity compared to protein g
sepharose for fat slow and maintains the
binding capacity over a wide range flow
rates this difference is achievable due
to the unique pore structure of portals
or stressors resins different from
traditional are girls resins and that
portals the be distracted by wide
through pores which unlocks the bead
interior allows for convective flow in
addition to much shallower diffusional
length since diffusional distances are
reduced mass transfer is improved this
means that as linear velocity increases
to the column capacity and resolution
are minimally effective we look at the
dynamic binding capacity of corals mat
capture ad select compare this with both
the Poros mat capture AG select and
pierce perching AE plus aw gross again
we see we show that dynamic binding
capacity on the x on the y-axis and on
the x-axis we have multiple flurries as
you can see mad capture HD select
maintains a five fold higher capacity
for human IgG over our girls resins and
multiple flurries similar to the format
captured G select the disc differences
scene due to the unique core structure
of corals however binding capacity is
just one of many variables when choosing
a good purification rhythm another trait
to look at his resolution these
chromatogram show up purification of
goat IgG from goat serum using three
different purification resins corals mag
capture G select
protein G sepharose for FAFSA and our
protein g + agarose resin
these resins were loaded with serum that
contain approximately 12 MiG's of IgG
in the chromatogram you can see that a
mad captured G select has a taller
evolution profile indicating a higher
binding capacity while also maintaining
a smaller Aleutian line the smaller
elution volume is again due to the
better mass transfer of the forest beat
in addition to the smaller beat size the
poor speed has an average particle size
of 50 microns while most are girls
residents has an average particle of 90
200 microns having a powerful size does
roughly the half the size of most other
residents allow for superior resolution
in these format grams again we show
purification using Poros mat captured G
select when protein G sepharose for
fascial but this time is in Mouse room
as you can see from the chromatograms
both residence has similar binding
capacity but mat capture jesus-like has
a more efficient mass transfer which
allows for the protein to be eluded in a
smaller body if we look at corals mad
capture 8 g selects we'll see a similar
story in these chromatograms reformed
purification with human syrup that
contain approximately 12 minutes of IgG
we can see that the mad capture AG
select maintains a higher binding
capacity while also having efficient
mass transfer
demonstrated by a smaller elution volume
lastly an important aspect of a
chromatography resin is a lifecycle of
the resin in this figure we identify if
the resin can be reused with minimal
changes to the chromatogram and purity
of knee antibody here we chose a single
one mil column of for us madcap Dorjee
selects and subjected it to 26
purifications in total 6 purifications
of IgG from serum and 20 Mach
purifications v first and every 5th
purification thereafter IgG was purified
from human serum while all other cycles
did not have any serum loaded on the
column
perform mock purifications a clean and
place consisting of 70% ethanol and 2
molar sodium chloride was performed
after all i GG and my purifications as
you see in the chromatogram the first
and the 26 run was identical and the job
below shows that the purity comparison
gained by Kumasi you remained assistant
throughout all the runs in addition we
didn't observe any noticeable leaching
of perching G from the resin we also
looked at the readability of porous mass
capture AG select again we took a 1 mil
column of porous mat capture AG select
and it was subjected to 26 purification
wheel total 6 purifications of IgG from
serum and 20 mark purifications
the first and every 5th purification
thereafter IgG was purified from human
serum while all other cycles did not
have any human serum loaded onto the
town for perform mock purifications a
clean and place consisting of 70%
ethanol and two molars unemployed was
performed after all IgG and MOC
purifications as you can see the
chromatograms of the 1st and 26th run
was identical and the gel below shows
the purity comparison by silver scene
remain constant through all the runs in
addition we did not observe any
noticeable Legion approaching AG from
the resin enclosing the new Poros mat
capture resins presented in this talk
showcased multiple advantages corals mat
captured GE and AG showed superior
dynamic by necessity over a wide range
of linear flow rates across multiple
species these resins allow for smaller
elution volume due to the core structure
of porous bead that allows for better
mass transfer and finally mad captured
GN AG can be reused multiple times
without changes to the peak shape or
purity and with that I'll take any
questions thank you
Aaron for that informative presentation
we will now start the live Q&A portion
of our webinar if you have questions
you'd like to ask please do so now which
is click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appear on your screen click on the send
button and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for so let's
get started with our first set of
questions what type of column do you
recommend for PRRS 50 on legends do I
need high pressure columns or portals so
the poor presents are mechanically rigid
and incompressible and so they can be
effectively packed in either low
pressure class columns or high pressure
stainless steel columns in additions the
columns can be packed in either
traditional flow axial compression or
packing place methods so really they can
be packed in just about any column you
need them to be packed in thank you so
much we have a set of questions coming
in here the next one how many uses
should I expect out of my Poros or
capture select column so really the
resident lifetime is dependent on how
the resin is used and the cleaning
process that is utilized
so really the purification process will
need to be evaluated specifically
especially and long life times desired
because the binding can be different
between resins and different cleaning
schemes so an optimized cleaning
procedure for any resin may yield less
than five uses while an optimized
cleaning process can be yield 100 or
more cycles for these resins we provide
recommendations of either with a 70%
ethanol cleaning followed by a 2 molar
sodium chloride cleaning and that has
shown from our data to really extend the
lifetime McConnel thank you
like we have one more question from our
audience members how many uses should I
expect out of my Poros and what type of
column do you recommend for I'm sorry
that one was already answered as well
okay I think you've answered both of
them thank you so much
if there aren't any more questions we're
going to go ahead and close did you have
any closing remarks that you'd like to
provide
not at this time I believe that the
presentation really showed the the use
and the benefits of the mat capture G
and AG select resins and if you guys
have any further questions I'd be I'd be
great to answer some wonderful thank you
I'd like to once again think our
presenter for today's presentation I'd
also like to think lab roots and thermo
Fisher Scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know that this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again stim bye bye